confirmed characters new leaks on the
character creator
and yes more controversy guys we have so
much to talk about you see 2021 has been
a
rocky year so far for hogwarts legacy we
do have what could be some legitimate
actual news about the game itself
specifically regarding some of its
characters as well as the game's
character creator
and we also have mention of a release
date and just how long we may be waiting
unfortunately we have even more negative
news around the game as one of its lead
designers will be leaving avalanche
studios very soon
all this comes after a journalist
brought to light some of the designers
old youtube videos and we'll cover it
all
in today's video people love the
internet retrorec and tour here if we're
meeting for the first time i'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories they
tell we post videos every week here on
youtube and if you're looking for more
hogwarts legacy videos featuring both
news and
theories on the game i've got you
covered be sure and check out my full
hogwarts legacy playlist which i'll have
a link to here at the end of the video
so as i mentioned in the beginning 2021
has been a tough year for hogwarts
legacy fans thus far
it all started with wb announcing a
delay rather early in the year and it
wasn't just for a few months but rather
the game was pushed all the way to 2022
hogwarts legacy also keeps getting
dragged into political controversies
regarding both author jk rowling as well
as troy levitt a lead designer on the
project who announced his resignation
from avalanche on march 4th
after announcing the resignation on his
twitter page levitt would go on to say
quote to clarify
i felt absolutely secure in my position
however i still wanted to resign for
reasons that i will explain
in that forthcoming video i'm in
excellent spirits and very pleased with
my relationship with wb
and avalanche closed quote his
employment with wb continues through
march 12th
at the time of recording this video
levitt has not yet posted the
aforementioned video update
of course this has generated a lot of
conversation among fans i should tell
you now this
is not going to be a rehash of
everything jk rowling has said or troy
levitt's youtube videos
and what all went into his resignation
you guys i'm just gonna be real with you
when i decided to start a youtube
channel i wanted to talk about
video games in fact politics would have
been the last thing i'd want to have
here
even the inner workings of game
development and game development
controversies
isn't really something that i would ever
have on my radar i just want to talk
about games i mean we start off and say
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell and that's really the
foundation of what the channel is
always meant to be about and so here on
this channel my commitment to you
is that it's about the games this is a
place for us to
break down those barriers that come
between us find a common interest with
video games we love
and unless the issues that come up
relate directly to the game itself as
they do in some items for today's video
then you probably won't hear me mention
them
now to be clear here i know there are a
lot of people out there who feel
strongly on
all sides of this equation from troy
levitt to jk rowling there are people
who have been hurt by a lot of these
comments
and so i want to be clear with you guys
i'm not saying that there isn't a
conversation
worth having here in fact a number of
conversations worth having
regarding all these issues it just means
this channel here
isn't the place for that discussion but
i also know there are so many people out
there of
all different backgrounds guys who just
want information about the game itself
and that's how i see my role on this
channel
in fact i think it would be a disservice
to you guys if all of a sudden i started
talking politics and telling you whether
you should or shouldn't support this
game because of this or that
i also know there are numerous devs at
avalanche devs that come from
many different backgrounds and beliefs
who just want to focus on making a good
game
so there's a lot at stake here there's a
lot going on here and i want to make
sure i'm being very respectful of those
devs and the work that they're putting
into this project
so i hope you guys will respect all of
that when you're interacting with one
another here in the comments and our
discord and on twitter
this is a family-friendly accepting and
loving community and as long as i'm
fortunate enough to have this channel
going
that's how it will continue to be so
with that let's get
to the news all right the first bit here
comes to us directly from
imdb and credit to at wikiharry potter
on twitter for finding this
julia farino hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly is an actress listed on imdb
who has an
updated profile that includes a role in
hogwarts legacy
at least she did have an updated profile
at the time of this recording both of
these listings have been removed in fact
you won't even find julia on the
hogwarts legacy page at all at least
that i could find
so to me that says that it is likely a
legitimate leak here someone probably
made a little accident posting that too
soon and now they've taken it down
personally i think it's a little strange
they would remove this since these
characters don't have names that are
instantly recognizable anyway
here's what the listing included it was
actually two roles and both were
mentioned by name
according to that listing which again
does not appear at this time
julia provides the voice for both a
cassandra mason and helen
thistlewood now lots of folks online
have been trying to piece this together
and find out if we possibly know either
of these names from the original series
thistlewood is not a name that we've
heard before we did
have a mr and mrs mason and harry potter
in the chamber of secrets
however mason is a rather common name so
for me at least it would be a bit of a
surprise if cassandra was somehow
related to that family
who met with uncle vernon way back in
the beginning of book 2 to discuss that
business deal which dobby promptly
ruined of course
now you can still go to imdb and check
out julia's full
acting credits to see what she has
experience in working at and one role
that jumped out to me
is that she did have a role in what
remains of edith finch
now there is a bit more information on
the imdb page that
hasn't been removed there is a listing
for hogwarts legacy and it has
five names mentioned there first up is
nathan hendrickson who is listed as the
cinematic director
nathan was also the cinematic director
for both shadow of war
and shadow of mordor of course jk
rowling is listed as the writer for
characters as well as the universe
then we also have another writer adam
covert who is written for games like
cars 3 and the disney infinity series
jillian petry is also credited as one of
the cast members however at the time of
this recording no specific characters
are listed
lawrence kern is credited as doing
motion capture for multiple characters
but again
no specific names here so out of all
that cassandra mason and helen
thistlewood very likely going to be
characters we'll meet in hogwarts legacy
at some point
now that's not all of the news we also
got a new leak courtesy of bloomberg's
jason
schreiber and this is regarding the
game's character creator so it seems
that several of these devs have pushed
hard for a character creator that will
be inclusive for
everyone so what that means is it's
going to allow body voice and gender to
be adjusted
independently of one another players
will also choose between witch
or wizard and that is what will
determine their dormitory
another interesting point here schreier
actually goes on to mention that the
game is quote at least
a year away and that last bit right
there may come as a tough blow to some
who i know were hoping that the game
would launch
maybe very early in 2022. at this rate
guys i'm just going to be honest with
you i'm not sure when to expect hogwarts
legacy to finally arrive i've been
reading gaming related news items where
other devs are talking about just how
difficult covet has made game
development in general
you see game development is such a
collaborative process and with so many
people working remotely it makes these
things even more difficult at times and
take
a lot more time than they normally would
there's also the issue of avalanche
losing troy
levitt who i believe was a lead designer
on the game i know there's been a little
bit of a question mark there because
some changes have been made to his
linkedin profile
but whatever the exact title was he did
have a leadership position
on this game so if we just look at this
from a pure development perspective here
ignoring all those kind of outside
issues
it can't be good to lose a prominent
team member just
after you announce a lengthy delay now
hopefully his resignation doesn't slow
them down too much there are likely
other dev members who
served a similar role and hopefully
they'll be able to find someone who can
fulfill his day-to-day duties
i do wonder i think it'll be interesting
to watch will they outright replace him
and bring in someone totally new to the
project
or will they do more of a thing where
they kind of divide up his job
responsibilities among others who are
already there and kind of know what's
going on
we will continue to report on hogwarts
legacy here but if you guys are new i do
have a harry potter let's play series up
on the channel i'll link that on the
left side of the screen
i'm also a huge animal crossing fan and
nintendo games in general so
lots of stuff here on the channel for
you to check out as always guys thank
you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon